hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about keto-adaptation symptoms and
solutions when you start the ketogenic
diet you may have any one of these
symptoms okay in this video we're going
to show you what to do okay so muscle
cramps that's usually a low potassium
situation so you need to increase your
potassium levels palpitations or heart
arrhythmias increase more potassium
because as you lose the glycogen Reserve
because you're not going to use as much
of it anymore you lose a lot of water
and with the water comes the
electrolytes so the need for potassium
will go way up so we want to increase
potassium here if you feel weak that
usually means you need more sodium sea
salt would handle that bad breath means
you're consuming too much protein cut
down the protein maybe add a little
apple cider vinegar for digestion dizzy
that can mean three things but when
we're doing keto it usually means that
you need to increase your sodium because
you're losing more fluid and the blood
pressures going to low so salt retains
water so you just need more sea salt and
water for that okay then we have fatigue
okay you need to up your b1 and b5
nutritional yeast works great for that
if you feel more cold especially and in
intermittent fasting take some iodine sea kelp you can also do sea vegetables as
well but you may just need to go with
the sea kelp a high quality would be
really good for that ok not satisfied
after a meal that means you need more
fat okay when your body adapts to
ketosis and you actually start healing
insulin resistance the need for fat goes
down because your body can now run on
your own fat but when you're first
starting out you're not as satisfied
increase the fat apple cider vinegar that
would be good now if you have right
shoulder pain that means you're
consuming too much fat or too many nuts
which is irritating the gallbladder
there's a nerve that goes to the right
shoulder it could be going up to your
neck or jaw or head or even a headache
right over here do you have those
symptoms cut back the fat and nuts and
that should completely go away
constipation okay you want to avoid too
much cheese cheese can constipate people
too much meat could constipate a person
increase the vegetables increase your
potassium if you're already doing that
you're going to
a lot of vegetables you can become
constipated from consuming too much of
the type of vegetables that you're not
used to so if you're doing the Kal sakes
or large quantities of vegetables then
you might need to cut down and consume
more fermented vegetables to handle this
so you always want to look back to what
happened just before you got constipated
did you start introducing something new
that will give you a clue on what's
causing it okay low back pain or
abdominal pain could mean you have a
little stone developing in the kidney in
which case you need to really
dramatically increase your potassium
levels you I would recommend a potassium
citrate like an electrolyte powder with
a lot of water that will greatly help
you in combination with a lot more
citrus so get some lemon juice in pour
about three to four ounces in a glass
and start consuming that that will
actually be really good to counteract
the stones and they're usually uric acid
stones they're not always oxalate stones
okay
they're the dreams that means you're low
in b1 nutritional yeast would help you or
sunflower seeds bloated okay cut down
the amount of fat increase apple cider
vinegar maybe get some support with bile
salts like in the gall bladder formula
that might help to if you have a rash
that could either mean you need more B
vitamins from nutritional yeast or the
liver is dumping toxins so you want to
make sure your vegetables are very very
high okay headaches means that you're
going too fast okay so you want to cut
it back so if you're doing intermittent
fasting two meals go to three meals if
you're doing one meal go to two meals so
just go a little slower because this
could be a blood sugar situation if
you're nervous have anxiety that means
you need B vitamins so nutritional yeast
that should take care of that
now if you want all of this on a little
card a cut out card that you can put in
your wallet I put a link down below so
you can download it and so that way you
could remember all these things all
right thanks for watching hey thank you
so much for watching keep spreading the
word and share this video